[Music]
have you guys seen on Twitter that
people are hanging up their Christmas
decorations
today it's insights I'm like cheer I
love it during this time Corona cheer
I love how three weeks ago people were
bagging on me if we're still having mine
up I finally took it down look at you
now look at you falling back
you know yeah mine are away we're not
putting back I'm not one of those people
our tree has three layers together
[ __ ] man yeah I get to judge people
now I had four in my old one figure we
have always but yeah so I'm gonna show
you guys some of these tweets where
people are having the holiday spirit
I love miss miss Layton yeah my
neighbors that put up lights yes this
one says there are dark times ahead but
I can still put up love and light out
into the world some folks have mentioned
putting up Christmas lights to cheer up
people in quarantine in isolation or
just to remind the world there's still
light and hope here's my contribution
it's a little heart shape nice cut to
Christmas everything is on fire there's
still a blinking Rudolph see I see the
scene in my exactly everything's like
dark and black oh yeah and there's like
ash for some reason like we should know
ways for Christmas early Christmas is
hell yeah here's the more so wow they
really went for it oh my is it also
snowing no or actually wait yeah and the
lad with the idea is awake sort of and
enjoying the snow-covered lights
that's really pretty if it looked like
that here I would do it they have been
knowing that there's no presence coming
his life ask an MS where we order off
online
there's everyday you could be having
presents I forget I'm an adult so you
want me to do that for you baby
yeah bottle of whiskey and then I'll
order you I'll order you 12 this
Christmas yeah twelve days of kovat
nineteen that's fun right don't you
sometimes yeah
I'm like oh yeah that's on me wow that
was on me I should've done what being an
adult yeah yes you or November you
sometimes I feel like that the work the
freight the word phrases would kind of
got me twisted up I don't know so
sometimes I feel like well everyone
laughs no sometimes I feel like I'm it
taught me to do things but I forget that
it's on me so this so I'm like oh I
didn't that he's an adult
yeah yeah yeah it's the power to make it
happen cuz usually I'll just do it for
you because it doesn't happen yeah won't
happen yeah yeah
that's true I think as husbands we all
revert back to being kids sometimes wife
do it for me please do it wife yeah or
why else did you marry them right
exactly although I will say that Steve
is really I think it's it's it's a good
trade-off I'll handle the finances and
bills and all the adult [ __ ] but he gets
me water when I'm like on the couch I'm
like anything if I even mentioned like
anything I want he's going to look well
he'll go out to the store and get it and
I'll put it in the group - whoa sick of
Nicky over here being so [ __ ] in love
it's so gross I was like I just casually
mentioned that I missed mango Jamba
Juice's and then Steve left didn't say
anything and five minutes later a Jamba
Juice was in my hand Wow again trying to
do an any man I know she's telling these
[ __ ] this [ __ ] well
somebody in the group chat was dating
and they were like oh it's you'll have
to settle on something or another and I
was like no you know you don't have to
settle for you I used to think you had
two standards and that donates you cuz
if you from the beginning you're like
hey we'll both help each other out
hey Jesse and Joey are both settling
there are both much happier now that's
also okay there you go circumstantial
evidence there you go
anecdotal evidence go be better - he
brings you like coffee and makes
breakfast - yeah he's [ __ ] tight and
he makes he makes michelin-star meals
Steve can't cook for you guys won't put
it like that grass is always greener
unless you make green you make the dope
drinks though I make the dog well Nicky
Mitchell dope drinks I know how to drink
though hey you'll go out and get
supplies for us to make I would in a
second that's why it's a good system
here just kidding you bought the heater
[ __ ] here every [ __ ] corner is
wrong
I like Geo stay home with Tiger today
yeah that's nice what do you do boy he
got us the the drink cart Longwood Joe
Oh a channel he started the channel I
feel like I'm the one filling in for Geo
today because you're in your spine no
because I mention I mentioned having I
know cuz I mentioned having a Christmas
tree and then to try to one-up my
Christmas tree so I'm fully being yeah
well no it's just a general
competitiveness I guess yeah these are
the competitive spirit
oh okay that's one get dunked on
well you wanted a this one getting
[ __ ] talked on in the gym the
backboard is getting Saturday Paula down
[Laughter]
no way at this point I don't even really
care about the Christmas holiday I mean
not that holiday the whole decorations
itself like it's this kind of God super
commercial so like I don't really I'm
put out of jack-o'-lantern I wait why
are you pissed about commercialism you
want to [ __ ] it on a Bentley yeah no no
no right I don't wait wait here we are
no my wanting a Bentley and I don't even
really want to Billie I'll be honest
with you but me wanting that that that
type of stuff is more so a rite of
passage for a certain level of success
it's like a symbol yeah passage family I
bought myself this nice gift because I
love cars yeah so this is our this this
is my right shoulder so but what I like
commercial is like like how every
holiday in the United States has a
reason to make you want to go out and
buy more or eat more like every holiday
and it's not really like highlighting
the real meaning of the holidays anymore
oh yeah Valentine Day is this app you're
like it's just a money pit the fact that
hearts are $10 so you want to read it
once and throw it away
what if you pitch it really sentiment
message he's ever given a gentleman
serial killer that that's what is like
the flower card thing is - oh yeah
everything we don't creep pictures out
you know why you know why so when you
first get in the argument she can like
remember in 2014 we used to love me
that's the only reason she dies it's all
up here
Wow about a year I'll tell you really
it's it's in your journals that's true
it's documented it's written it and it's
file
it's by all the way here you have a lot
of damage in your life I think I do
I just I'm a Scrooge I'm a screws but I
I have nice waist nice things that I'll
do for people good guy man I don't like
I don't need all that I don't need all
those no you're a good guy I know it
Bentley except that would be for me it's
just cuz I like cars would you drive it
yourself huh I wouldn't get anything
that I need to be chauffeured if I need
you to be chauffeured around I would
just hire somebody for their job to
support a business I don't need
something that I need to be doing around
I like driving my horse yeah I'll never
like I wouldn't want like a big bill how
we get a race I like I like is such it's
a cool but much more Marty yeah yeah
yeah yeah the stars in the head like I
don't yeah that's all I need I wanted to
ask Martin Vanquish but then I found out
that man this is a [ __ ] [ __ ] on
super still want a yacht no I don't want
to I was I was visualizing a yacht I
like your style dude James Bond style
what's your PB you can't so much me
right after Martin Vancouver I get
seasick you could just maybe just rent
one for like a week like yeah you don't
need to own that times up unless unless
you like ready to end blood cuz you
gotta have like flop make it yeah yeah
the whole crew I even got invited to
parties on yachts and I said no because
I get so seasick oh I do not enjoy
yachts but you don't want to jump off
from the second floor enjoy yeah we
don't one yacht before which was my
aunt's wedding like it was her third
wedding but like it she went all out and
she did this yacht and it was only for
an hour and I was like bro we got to be
on here for it now like we were dancing
and like open bar it was like tight that
she had a good spread good open bar
everything but I was just like oh it was
there you can tell that they only got it
for an hour or two because I get 45
minutes late yo guys start start moving
out of here man we're gonna have to pay
for the spillover there's a spillover
charge get off the [ __ ] boat
[Laughter]
throwing kids in the water is yes that
would be awesome
I will only want to be definitely the
bloody marys everywhere Oh everybody's
certain blouse longer than and like I
could be in a boat for an hour like when
we do it when we go to Catalina you know
that oh that ferry yeah that two hours
exactly so after an hour I start getting
oh I threw up up ton on that ferry I
have to see a consistent buzz for me to
not get drunk I like being on ships and
boats because they I feel like because I
do get seasick I think I for some reason
think that drinking does get rid of the
seasickness does it's just a great
excuse to get [ __ ] blood that's like
cruises we work through I project how
vomited in my room on the last cruise I
wanna yeah in the room it smelled like
vomit [ __ ] forever it felt like a
prison with a water slide on it no I got
from that wide people kissed the ground
in movies after the get off the boats
all of it I was so sick he threw up in
the where was it yes I threw up outside
of the man yeah epic ocean or Atlantic
Ocean so cific okay I will never do a
cruise in the Pacific Ocean ever again
one that we did projector it was so bad
it was like super super choppy choppy
that's the word and then I had sea legs
afterwards for like a few days and all
that Oh cruises are horrible but then we
took a cruise in the Caribbean from the
Atlantic side and oh it was a whole new
direction so that was boozy I never went
on a Caribbean cruise
that invited your private island Oh
simply don't go to the door we never
Cruise in the Pacific [ __ ]
the Sun is where the help cruises
there's so many like things there it
like it the water so calm tell that to
the Titanic there's like I was on a
cruise ships like I was like who's met
this lovely couple
and then I asked what do you do and she
said oh I'm a maid and I said get me off
of this on the wrong boat are you on
break
[Laughter]
[Music]